precisely and it's not real but it's his
perspective
so therefore it becomes his reality you
cannot change somebody's reality
what you can do is you can give them
information so that they change their
perspective
when they change their perspective then
their reality changes
all right so paradigm shift yeah
exactly so now here's how it works
this is what i'm telling you that i've
heard time and time again well from
these people when they renounce
like when they first walk into the room
and see me or or
encounter me wherever their wall goes
right up
i am the enemy i am inferior to them
and they want to radiate hate towards me
you know i
i you know that's what makes them a
supremacist because i'm inferior
all right so they're going to be on the
offense
and you know it's what that guy telling
me
that uh i'm a criminal and that i'm lazy
and my brain is small so i'm dumb um
is that offensive of course it's
offensive
am i offended by it absolutely not
most people would be offended by that
but i'm not offended by it
not because it's true the reason why i'm
not offended by it is because it's not
true
why should i be offended by a lie this
guy doesn't know me
he only met me five ten minutes ago and
he's telling me
based on the color of my skin that i'm
dumb and that i'm prone to crime
and that i'm lazy now if my parents told
me that
i might have some concerns because you
know they brought me into this world
they know me better than anybody else
you know daryl you know you're you know
you're kind of dumb
okay well maybe i am all right but not
some guy who just met me 10 minutes ago
uh so don't let your emotions get in
front of you
all right they don't know you so why
believe them don't be offended by a lie
all right so what i did was i threw them
off their game
their wall is up and
normally when you tell somebody all this
vitriol they're gonna start pushing back
right because you know they're not put
up with that you know because they're
offended now
their emotions have gotten in front of
them these people are used to that
they're used to offending people
that's why they're in the clan right but
you know you're not used to being
offended
so they they are the experts at this
and so um
don't let them push your buttons sit
back
now here's something that i've learned
as a kid i told you i traveled a lot as
an adult i travel a lot
performing or giving lectures around the
world when you combine
my childhood travels with my adult
travels
to to this date i've been in a total of
different countries on six continents
wow i've been exposed
to a multitude of cultures colors of
skin
religions beliefs you name it i've seen
a lot of them
all right and when i come back home
and i think about the people i've met
the places i've gone
the things i've seen i conclude one
thing
no matter how far i go or how close i go
whether i go right next door to canada
or
this side to mexico or whether i go to
the other side of the earth
when i get back home i conclude one
thing
everybody i've seen no matter how
different what language they speak what
who they worship or what not we all are
human beings
and as such we all want the same
basic five things we want to be loved
we want to be respected we want to be
heard
we want to be treated fairly we want the
same things for our family
as anybody else wants for their family
as long as we understand that
and keep those five core values there
and apply them wherever we go we can
navigate
any society the clan is just another
society to me
all right they want the same things i
want you know
for their family they want to be heard
they want to be respected
they want to be treated fairly all this
kind of stuff so if i apply those things
i can get along right we may not agree
on certain things obviously
i don't respect what they say
i will never respect what they say right
but i will respect their right to say it
because we do have the right to freedom
of speech right right so i give them
that
um people want to be heard i'm allowing
him to be heard
he's telling me i'm a criminal and i'm
lazy i'm on welfare and
and uh my brain is small i'm allowing
him to be heard
you know let him be heard so what what
i'm doing is i'm not pushing back
i'm but i'm not kissing his butt either
i'm just you know giving him that
respect
[Music]
i'm lowering that wall that wall is
coming down
because normally within 45 seconds
somebody's gonna be pushing back on them
what do you think that is about you that
makes you able to have the conversation
with somebody who's blatantly insulting
you
and to be able to to keep that sense of
calmness
and keep us and maintain a civil
conversation and discourse because i
view racism as a disease
it's a disease of the mind and you know
we don't
you know we can't we can't always fault
somebody if they're sick
you know there's no way in hell this guy
has seen as much as i've seen
right you know he hasn't been to 57
countries
you know he hasn't even been to 50
cities he has probably
even been 50 miles from where he lives
you know
he lives in a bubble that's a really
good point yeah that's right so
i try to you know to understand that
um he's wrong you know
but i try to bring him what i've seen
vicariously and realize he's not had the
same exposure that i have
one of my favorite quotes of all time is
by
mark twain and it's called the travel
quote
and mark twain said travel is fatal to
prejudice and narrow-mindedness
and many of our people need it sorely on
these accounts
broad wholesome charitable views of men
and things
cannot be acquired by vegetating in one
little corner of the earth all one's
lifetime
that is so true you know had i grown up
here in this country my whole life
would i be doing this work today
probably not probably stay as far away
from those people as i could
but because i've seen things i've been
around different people i got along with
different people from all over the world
i know it can work he doesn't know that
because he hasn't had that experience
again one's perspective is one's reality
you know right okay so i'm lowering the
wall
by allowing him to be heard get it all
out
i'm showing him that respect of
listening to him
i'm treating him fairly you know it's
your turn to talk go ahead you know
and he's insulting me and whatever else
that wall is coming down
now that he has exhausted all his
vitriol
and i've listened to him and i've shown
him that respect
he feels compelled to reciprocate
and allow me to present my platform you
know what i have to say
now it's my turn to talk
i could go on the offense and attack him
for attacking me
and i would be well within my right to
do so i could say no
you're the one who's a criminal you're
the one who's hanging black men from
trees
and bombing black churches and dragging
black men behind pickup trucks and so
forth and so on
i could attack him because everything i
just said is true
all those things have happened with the
clan right so i would be right to say
that
but if i attack him like that the wall
go right back up
i want to keep the wall down so i can
plant a seed
when the wall is up you can't plant a
seed the seed hits the wall and falls
back on your side
when the wall is down you can plant a
seed over the wall into his turf
all right so now the wall is down rather
than go on the offense
i go on the defense and in
my defense is an offense in a way
i'm subtly planting the seed instead
instead of attacking him i said you know
i hear what you're saying however
i don't have a criminal record nobody in
my family has a criminal record
i've never been on welfare nobody in my
family's ever been on welfare
as far as brain size goes i've never
measured my brain but i'm sure it's the
same size
as anybody else's and as far as sats go
my s.a.t scores were high enough to get
me into college
i have a bachelor's degree both my
mother and father
had not had master's degrees my dad was
working on his phd before he passed
so i'm saying all this defending myself
but i'm letting him know that we have
education we don't have we're not on
welfare we don't have any criminal
record
right i could throw it in his face
because i know he barely made it out of
high school
all right but if i throw that in his
face knowing that i have more
intelligence
in my little finger than he and his
whole clan put together
that would just cause the wall to go
back up so here's what happens
when the wall is down he hears when the
wall is up just like this
he didn't hear anything you say so he's
heard me he goes home
and he and he reflects upon what
transpired that day
damn you know i had a a conversation
with a black guy for three hours
you know and we didn't come to blows
that's never happened before
you know and what that daryl guy said
about such-and-such makes sense
but he's black but what he said was true
but he's black
so he's having a cognitive dissonance
you know
he knows what i said to be true either
because he researched it and found out
that it was true
or he already knew it to be true but he
does not want to accept the fact that
the truth came
from a black source that just does not
compute right in his world
okay but but so he struggles back and
forth so
he's left with this dilemma do i
disregard that guy's skin color
and believe the truth because i know
it's true and change my direction
or do i consider his skin color and know
he's telling me the truth but go on
living a lie
that's his dilemma so in most cases
these people
will opt for the truth but there are
times though
and people who will never change they
will go to their grave
being hateful violent and racist all
right
um i i've met some of those people too
but anybody who even has those feelings
if they're willing to sit down and have
a conversation with you
there is an opportunity to plant that
seed but you got to do it the right way
you can't attack attack attack
you do a subtle attack by defending and
then let him reflect on what you've
on what you've done what you've said in
your defense and then that makes him
think
because he he hears that when you're
attacking him he's not hearing it
the wall is up he's blocking it out
you